wearing a corset does you know you feel
like you can't breathe sometimes
period pieces are a dream the ball gowns
sophisticated parties
the romance all things we've wanted to
experience at least
once in our lives however no matter how
cool it was on screen
the behind the scenes wasn't as
picture-perfect for some actresses
why the corsets that's why we're
uncovering the corset-wearing nightmare
actresses like elle fanning and millie
bobby brown had to go through
by the end of it you'll totally
understand why emma watson refused to
wear one when she starred in beauty and
the beast
that's it cara delevingne loved her time
on carnival row as vignette but she
totally could have done without one
thing
her costume specifically her core set
she would be laced into her outfit
so tightly that by the end of every day
she didn't have any voice left to speak
with the corset
literally took her breath and voice away
she said that she completely understands
how women used to feel
when they were forced to wear corsets in
public every day
and even compared them to a muzzle yikes
dearest readers every day on set of
bridgerton was a struggle for phoebe
denevere
and that's because her character
daphne's costumes were just
too restrictive the actress wasn't even
able to move around properly at first
and at the end of the day she was left
with markings on her body from where the
corset would dig in
all she had to say was thank god we've
come a long way from wearing these
however she is counting her blessings
considering she was lucky enough to only
require a half corset that was perfectly
fitted to her body
yours truly the things whatever will
they think
doesn't matter we were so surprised to
find out that even at such a young age
millie bobby brown was required to wear
a corset for her role as a nola
in enola homes millie says what made the
corset wearing even worse was that she
had to perform coordinated stunts in it
she couldn't even wrap her head around
having to do the stunts she was training
for with a
giant wooden thing wrapped around her we
bet the upside down couldn't even
prepare her for that
but although it was uncomfortable she
eventually adapted to the corset and was
able to move a lot better with it on as
time passed
we're gonna use your corset to an
advantage and we've really brought some
cool feminine qualities into the fights
we're all familiar with the
characteristic original disney
princesses used to have
the smallest waist possible so when lily
james starred in the live-action
cinderella
she hopped into a corset immediately of
course it pulls it in and then the skirt
makes it bigger so i think the
perspective makes it look
even smaller the corset was so tight
that the public thought they had
digitally enhanced her waist to be
smaller
her meals on set consisted solely of
liquids because any other food wouldn't
digest while wearing a corset she also
had to take breaks while dancing because
she couldn't breathe properly with it on
i learned this course it's really hard
to breathe but
lily said luckily she had been used to
corsets already from her time on downton
abbey elle fanning's body completely
changed from wearing a corset for her
film the great
she said that you hear so many actresses
talk about it and it's 100
the truth it's no surprise considering
she literally had to relearn how to
breathe with it on
not to mention film high movement stunt
scenes long character monologues while
filming
apparently they were also absolutely
impossible for elwha filming
it is art but there's another side to it
as well
imagine not being able to sit down for
an entire day that's how emma stone's
life was while filming her movie the
favorite her costume required a corset
which
literally made her organs shift saying
that it was gross
it was gross she also wasn't able to
breathe for the entire first month of
wearing the corset but it did make her
more understanding of women from the
time period
women existed in that for such a long
time which does give you a lot of
sympathy for that time period kate
winslet is an absolute
trooper not only did she wear a corset
for the titanic but she got back into
one for her films finding neverland
and a little chaos even after calling
the experience of wearing a corset a
nightmare
wearing corsets is a nightmare i'm not
gonna pretend it's easy
she's never excited to have them
incorporated in her wardrobe but it's
the price she has to pay for loving to
work on period pieces
it was fun if you know occasionally a
little painful i did feel lucky
the marvelous mrs maisel is an
absolutely stunning show but at a pretty
high price
actors like rachel brosnahan had bodily
injury from how tight the corsets she
had to wear were
she wasn't able to breathe properly
while filming which made delivering her
lines and speaking quickly
pretty difficult she says she's still
not able to take proper breaths even
without wearing it
some of my ribs are sort of fused
together a little bit and i can't take
super deep breaths anymore we couldn't
ask for a better superwoman than gal
gadot
and if you thought she wasn't dedicated
now wait until you hear what she told
jimmy kimmel
her costume that consists of a corset
was excruciatingly tight during her
first fitting
but she didn't say a word and played it
off like a professional
take a listen it was so tight and i
literally
could not breathe however the costume
designers eventually noticed and
adjusted it better to
her body although it was adjusted she
still needed to get out on set and
perform some
pretty intense action scenes and you do
feel the way
of the responsibility by portraying her
we all loved when we got to see another
side of nina dobrev on the vampire
diaries however
catherine's period costumes were a far
cry from her doppelganger elena's
sneakers and jeans
nina may have loved playing catherine
but she could have done without the
corsets
like a lot of actresses she wasn't able
to breathe and eventually had instances
where she almost
passed out after 16 hours of filming
she's really actually disgusting
in real life in real life sercia ronan
put on a corset for her role in mary
queen of scots
her advice stay in school don't do
corsets
sercia wore the corsets for so long that
her body shape didn't return back to
normal until
months after filming apparently it felt
like it was squashing her insides
ouch like we'd have it on for you know
12 hours a day
yeah and it's tight corsets are tight
sercia wasn't the only one who had a
tough time with the corsets on the show
margot robbie called her corset and
layers of clothing very restrictive
she wasn't able to breathe properly but
ultimately found a way to use her
breathing issues as an advantage
apparently not being able to breathe
works perfectly for acting out scenes
where she was meant to be frustrated
good to know actually the costumes too
were very restrictive you're wearing a
corset and layer after layer i mean
they're incredibly heavy
natalie dormer just can't seem to stay
away from the corsets
she's had to wear one in projects like
game of thrones tudors
the scandalous lady w and picnic at
hanging rock
she's constantly making oaths about
never doing a project that requires a
corset
but ultimately keeps breaking it off her
key to surviving is constantly hydrating
herself
especially while filming in hotter
climates but
taking off her core set at the end of
the day isn't the most
pleasant thing for people around her if
you catch her drift
kira knightley who else could play a
better elizabeth swan
well women in london must have learned
not to breathe
you'd think that her taking on more
corset corset-wearing projects
like the duchess means she doesn't mind
them but that isn't the case
she finds it especially difficult to
film emotional scenes
which her movies tend to have a lot of
all she wants after a 16-hour long day
wearing one is to breathe a little bit
she completely relates to how women were
constantly fainting during the time
period
so the the opportunity to play her was
just one that i couldn't pass up
we're betting l and dakota fanning have
had conversations about how terrible
wearing a corset is dakota said the
fitting for the alienist
involved trying on corset after corset
it was so
taxing that she fainted overall it was
just painful and annoying
even when she began adjusting however
she is thankful for the corsets in the
sense that it really helped her get into
character
do you agree with emma watson's decision
yet it's eye-opening to see how much
some of these actresses went through
just to bring us our favorite
productions and characters they deserve
all of the awards which actor do you
think went through the most when it came
to corset wearing